if you guys were wondering when me and
Cody start our queer baiting fetish site
it's going to be called limp biscuits
it's going to be us like just blue ball
on you because we'll do the initial
scenes of like a gay porn but then
nothing will happen because neither of
us what are the official scenes of a gay
porn um I don't know just chatting and
hanging you so you've seen them yeah the
initial scenes of the gay porn kind of
go like this
you want to do some gay porn
yeah you want to [__] yeah yeah it's
only two minutes long I'm gonna come me
too
in two minutes now what we're describing
is uh like straight gay porn
like we're not actually gay like like
because we're like straight dudes but
I'm wondering yeah how do I pull some up
let's go